Miriam marges is probably best known as
a cute little old lady who played
Professor sprout in Harry Potter so why
did Arnold swarchenegger intentionally
fart in her face 1988's Rayman cleaned
up at the Oscars taking home four Awards
including best picture for his portrayal
of Raymond babbit the svant brother to
Tom Cruz's Charlie Dustin Hoffman took
home the best actor in the leading role
trophy it's second time winning the
award in an interview with Esquire
Hoffman shared his thoughts on why
Rayman was such a hit using one
particular scene as an example you take
the laugh out of Rainman and it's not
the same movie I went in the phone booth
and I fart that was a fart that wasn't
written in the script we were waiting to
do the shot and Barry levenson had the
earphones on the door closed and I snuck
one out we're tight in there you know
and Cruz looked at me and said did you
fart and I said yeah but I stayed in
character oh fart yeah Charlie bab I'll
hold fart did you fart R fart levenson
heard the whole thing and found it
hilarious so Hoffman's fart made the
Final Cut Hoffman said that's a good
director someone who takes advantage of
accident can you stand it I don't mind
it how can you stand Saturday Night Live
icon Kate McKinnon has moved on to the
big screen in films like the 2023 meah
hit Barbie one of her breakthrough roles
was in the 2016 reboot of Ghostbusters
although the film failed to excel at the
box office it still allowed McKinnon to
humorously choose scenery with fellow
SNL alums Leslie Jones and Kristen wig
it should come as no surprise that the
tri along with Melissa McCarthy brought
a whole lot of laughs to the Ghostbuster
set in an interview with Entertainment
Weekly McKinnon owned up to being a tad
gassy while shooting all right whatever
I farted on camera I'm starting to think
something is wrong with me I've never
been to a gastroenterologist because to
me it's always been normal but I'm
starting to feel like it's too much they
ought to get it checked out box and
Recreation may have experienced a shaky
start but after seven seasons and a
prestigious Golden Globe win it's safe
to say that the show ended up being a
massive success with a cast including
comedic Geniuses like Chris Pratt Amy
Poler Aubrey Plaza and Nick Offerman how
could it not be in March 2019 the cast
reunited in Hollywood for Paley Fest to
celebrate the show's 10-year anniversary
while answering questions ore Plaza
disclosed which cast member made her
favorite noises that is so annoying
because Nick and Pratt used to fart all
the time and it would make Amy and I
really angry it may seem odd to hear
Chris pratz now known for his big
blogbuster movies be so open about his
flatulence but it sounds just about
right for his character Andy DWI he
sneezed and smacked his head against the
wall it sounds about right most actors
who break wind on set do so by mistake
however that wasn't the case when alter
bankstar melin Klein lets out to toot on
the set of the hit show and she did it
on purpose the actor and her co-star
Austin North were prepping for her first
onscreen romantic encounter and she
thought that the best way to ease the
palpable tension in the air was by
letting one rip kin said in an inter
interview with fol we didn't really know
each other that well at that point and
we hadn't really spent too much time
hanging out here to break the I through
were sitting in the Green Room Austin
and I twiddling our thumbs and trying to
make conversation and I could tell that
he was nervous and I knew he could tell
I was nervous so I just farted in front
of him North retreated to a corner of
the room to escape the fart but he
apparently found the whole thing
hilarious samow Jackson and Brie lson
evidently developed quite a bond during
their time together on the sets of
various movies the do who first worked
together on the set of Kong Skull Island
back in late 2015 co-starred in Captain
Marvel and in lon's featurelength
director Royal debut unicorn store on
Netflix Jackson told reporters during a
set visit we're very good friends we
work well together it's fun to be on the
saddle with her on James cordon's carpo
karaoke Jackson and lson each took turns
taking a polygraph test and Lon received
a shocking answer after asking Jackson
if had ever farted while filming a scene
oh the
time what digging in lson followed up by
asking if he farted while they were
doing the light detector test Jackson
responded that he did not but the
bodygraph declared otherwise Christen
sha the sidesplitting Emmy nominee who
voices Louise beler in Bobs Burgers is
no stranger to funny business with a
resume chug full of small rolls in some
of the world's most prestigious comedies
Char has really made a name for herself
in Hollywood over the past decade in
foxes the last man on Earth charl and
fellow comic Will Forte played two of
the last humans in a post-apocalyptic
World naturally hilarity ensues so just
farting a Late Night with Seth Meyers sh
revealed that preparation for a love
scene combined with a scene that
required her to eat a copious amount of
beans had in unplanned result Carol is
aggressively and sexually talking to
Phil that's a lot of diaphragm work
which is also in the danger zone of
where the beans are finally I just
looked at will and I was like I'm going
to fight on you and I did after to do
the nest need to have some beans showing
no shame whatsoever sh only backed up a
stinky action with pride if you fart on
your scene partner it's the most
intimate you can get the late Andre the
Giant who sadly died in 1993 truly lived
up to his name the French wrestler was a
mountain of a man standing 7' 4 and
weighing in at an astounding 500
although he was best known for his work
in the ring Andre did also play Parts in
a few movies and television shows
perhaps his most recognized role was
that of fezzik in 1987's The Princess
Bride starring alongside the likes of
Carrie elz Robin Wright and Mandy pankin
Andre gave his co-stars Cobia stories
from their time shared on set such as
reportedly racking up a $40,000 bartab
at his hotel more speaking to Sports
Talk Florida in 2014 elw shared another
Andre story that surely had fans and
stitches my first day working with Andre
the Giant he didn't finish his line he
barely got through when he let out the
most extraordinary giant Mammoth fart
that you've ever heard in your whole
life I mean a 15-second emission of gas
the set rumbled everyone thought it was
like an earthquake it was so insanely
loud I mean imagine a Giant's
fog and and and we all got ttis from it
it's got to be intimidating for a young
actor to share the screen with one of
the world's biggest stars such as the
conundrum that James makoy found himself
in 2007 was shooting the bullet bending
action flick wanted his co-star Angelina
jool Le have been named Esquire
Magazine's sexiest woman in 2004 and the
already taken home an Oscar for her role
in 2000's girl interrupted by contrast
makavo had only a few roles under his
belt at that time as his 2007
breakthrough atonement hadn't yet hit
theaters when wanted began filming in
order to beef up and look the part of an
action hero producers had makavo take
muscle gain supplements speaking to
Cosmopolitan the actor revealed that the
supplements had quite a nasty downside
to be fair it really helped but it came
with a massive side effect of me
violently farting it was so often and so
vigorous I couldn't stop when I was
filming I was by far the biggest fter in
Hollywood that's probably not the
impression you want to make when
shooting scenes was one of the sexiest
women alive before he became a teenage
heart throb for his portrayal of Peter
Malak in the Hunger Game series Josh
Hutcherson nabbed a small part in
Roberts me's imaginative 2004 Christmas
film The Polar Express starring Tom
Hanks via motion capture Hutcherson
played a young boy who was struggling to
recover his belief in Santa Claus Hanks
played a slew of parts in the movie
including that of a hobo at one point in
the film Hutcherson's character skis
down the top of the train with a hobo
meaning that Hutcherson fully garbed in
the necessary moap dots basically sat on
Hank's lap to shoot the scene in late
2017 over a decade after the film
theatrical release hon went on The Late
Late Show with James Corin the sure
behind the scenes tidbit about the
production that no one knew I farted in
the scene it happened I did it my first
big movie Tom HS from Roberts Z mechis
and I just farted in his face and
instead of like playing it cool Tom
Hanks is like whoa whoa oh my God this
kid what the heck Peter Jackson's The
Lord of the Rings trilogy took years to
make with a casting crew relocating to
New Zealand for most of it Elijah Wood
spent 16 months in the scenic country
during the filming of the hit trilogy
and some of that time it was farting in
2023 would revealed on the popular
YouTube series hot ones it was the first
day of filming day one the scene is we
are rolling down the hill after Mary and
Pippen run into US running away from
farmer maggot's field having stolen a
bunch of vegetables they Bang into us we
roll down the hill the hobbits end up in
a heap at the bottom of the hill piled
on top of each other it's a funny scene
but the biggest laugh that day didn't
come from the comical tumble they had a
what is that a concussion fart a fart
that is brought on by pressure everybody
bursts out laughing there a hell of a
way to start filming Lord of the Rings
action Superstar Arnold schwarzeneger
has fronted some memorable movies over
the years but he has also had a share of
forgettable pictures including the
supernatural Thriller end of days the
most notable thing about this '90s flop
is that it spawned a bizarre story about
Anie intentionally farting in the face
of a coaster the victim of said f was
Miriam marges best known for playing
Professor sprout in the Harry Potter
films the actor is known for speaking
her mind and that's exactly what she did
when she was a guest on the podcast I've
got news for you swarzenegger didn't
care for him he's a bit too full of
himself he farted in my face now I fart
of course I do but I don't fart in
people's faces he did it deliberately
right in my face to add insult to injury
it wasn't even a situation that maraliz
could get away from they were in the
middle of a scene when the incident took
place and she was trapped she explained
I was playing Satan's sister and his
character was killing me so he had me in
a position where I couldn't ES Escape
lying on the floor and he just farted
whoopy Goldberg is one of the few people
who have won the egot as she has taken
home an Emmy a Grammy an Oscar and a
Tony Award one of her Daytime Emmy
Awards came in 2009 for co-hosting The
View on which she became a fixture in
2023 whoopy made waves when what sounded
like a fart was heard on the set of the
talk show for which she apologized but
co-host Sunny hen later confirmed that
this particular noise was actually made
by someone's mugs SC against the table
and Goldberg was just joking around when
she said sorry it was all too believable
though because whoopy has done it before
yeah you're so oh excuse me in fact the
name whoopy actually comes from how much
she fart yes it's true Goldberg whose
real name is Karen Johnson told the New
York Times in 2006 that she chose her
stage name due to her prodigious fatting
when you're performing on stage you
never really have time to go into the
bathroom and and close the door so if
you get a little gassy you've got to let
it go so people used to say to me you
are like a whoopy cushion and that's
where the name came from if you can't
handle a fart you can't handle me Tom
Hanks a man who has been affectionately
called America's dad is one of the most
well respected actors of the past 30
plus years the two-time muscar winner
just carries himself in a way that makes
him nearly impossible to dislike and for
the most part his movies are very
successful one of his top grossing films
2006 is The Da Vinci Code made over $760
million worldwide but the real Holy
Grail of that movie was a pretty
humorous behind thescene story that
happened during production in an
interview with Yahoo Paul betany who
plays the film's main antagonist shed
some light on what can happen if you
punch Tom Hanks too hard on camera the
first time I punched him during the
first scene I was on set for doing The
Da Vinci Code I punched him and he
farted HKS just looked at me and said
you just made me fart isn't that funny I
loved him for that these days Sarah
chalk is best known for providing the
voice of Beth Smith Morty's perpetually
annoyed mother in Rick and Morty but
before that she played Dr Elliot Reed on
Scrubs for nearly a decade and during
that time she farted in 2023 chalk was a
guest on Zack Brath and Donald Faison's
podcast fake doctors real friends but
chalk detailed the incident which took
place while she and Brath were preparing
for a kissing scene we're standing there
like over in the corner and they're
about to say rolling and I may or may
not have farted Zach just made the
biggest deal anyone could possibly make
over somebody fting I think he made a
song and there was some clapping
involved in it in 2009 will frell and
Anna field start in Universal's big
screen reboot of the 70s TV show land of
the lust a dinosaur themed Adventure
series for kids dur filming it turns out
there was a lot of farting going on and
it wasn't all from Will Ferrell in a
2017 interview with the portable
infinite F explained that a bows of
gassiness left her embarrassed until
feral decided to play along I was
drinking all these organic drinks and
they gave me guft gas it was
uncomfortable for a few days then Will
Ferrell told me he was building up some
gas and he had one coming he farted for
more than 10 seconds and it was a
gentlemanly thing to do after that
everything was fine Star Trek fans have
been organizing conventions for more
than 50 years with dedicated Gatherings
happening all around the world at an
appearance celebrating their years on
Star Trek Voyager Garrett Wong Tim Russ
and Robert picardo discussed farts in
the final frontier as Wong put it fart
wars went on on the Voyager set it turns
out one of the biggest Defenders was
co-star Robert Duncan mcneel who engaged
in an ongoing fart battle with Russ
picardo said I used to refer to Tim as
the man the myth the methane according
to Russ he was simply countering other
people's farts with his own I had to
defend myself I am the Tactical officer
after all when it comes to awkward
moments passing gas in front of all your
co-workers while on the job it's right
up there but for Spider-Man no way home
actor Tom Holland it was even worse
because the coworker he tooted in front
of was was also his girlfriend Zena who
played Spider-Man's love interest MJ
worse still it wasn't just in front of
her it was while he was strapped to her
Holland recounted the incident during a
group's Serious XM interview with Zena
and fellow co-star Jacob botan yeah I
farted no one did you yeah I farted on
you unfortunately yeah it's tough the
suit's tight the harness squeezes out
according to the actor the incident
occurred while filming one of the movies
highflying stunts where Spider-Man grabs
MJ and goes for a swing suspect Ed by
wires there was really nowhere to go and
no way to get away from the far for Zend
DEA it wasn't a situation she could
ignore or brush off sorry about that
graciously Holland didn't try to hide it
quickly confessing and apologizing of
course trying to deflect blame in that
situation would have been fruitless it's
a superhero movie equivalent to someone
breaking wind in an elevator when
there's only one other person there you
Canad ignorance but you both know the
truth Wiki jaes is one of the most
celebrated comedians of his generation
the Brit has been awarded an acting
Golden Globe two prime time Emmys a few
bafs and a couple of British Comedy
Awards not to mention the countless
other nominations garnered throughout
his storyed career so it's good to hear
that even with such a lofty resume jaes
is still a childish Joker behind the
scenes during an episode of his
award-winning series extras javes shared
screen time with Kate winsler according
to Winslet javes did his best to make a
break character by breaking wind she
said Ricky jaas is Dreadful because he
tries to you up he'll fart in the middle
of scene and he won't crack a smile the
guess must not have been too bad however
because Winslet still looks back at her
time on Extras with high regard I don't
think I ever got through a take without
peeing myself laughing we've all been at
a gathering where someone inadvertently
lets a fart loose it's uncomfortable but
everyone eventually moves on when it
happened to Alex marfit on Christmas
with the cbles though it wasn't quite so
simple the story comes to us via the
film star Justin L who spoke to
news.com.au about the incident there was
a scene where we were shooting late at
night everybody was a little Punchy you
know and Alex had eaten a bunch of I
forget what they were serving for dinner
but it was something that was giving
everybody gas and this wasn't a oneoff
mind you the problem was that maet just
could not stop farting according to Long
maet kept acting despite his upset
stomach pausing every now and then to
release a rumbler like it had been
scripted soon enough long was joining in
and the whole thing turned into a rather
stinky competition Long said I tried to
squeeze out a few when we were just
going back and forth it was ridic
ridiculous in the end director CLA
neerum had to step in and shut it down
according to long she said okay guys
that's really funny let's do one without
all the farts following Marian coa's
performance and Christopher Nolan's
Inception the french actor reunited with
the director for The Dark Knight risers
and has since start in a number of big
English language movies including the
World War II romantic drama Allied one
film that the Oscar winning actor St in
that isn't so well loved however is the
critically panned video game adaptation
Assassin's Creed and according to
co-star Michael fasbender the French
Beauty gave her own review of the film
when she broke wind more than once
during the making of the film when the
pair sat down with Yahoo to promote the
movie they were asked about any shameful
secrets from the set fast Bender was
quick to respond saying to COA you're
flatulence but we're not going to talk
about that that wouldn't be right CA
laughed and playfully scolded her
co-star for his oversharing saying
please let me be a glamorous actress
fast Bender then defended her with a
shrug pointing out that it's a perfectly
normal bodily function real F let's face
it the in betweeners might just be the
most iconic British team comedy ever the
show Chronicles the lives of a group of
boys as they come of age while attending
a typical British school the show was
praised for its realistic and hilarious
portrayal of teenage problems but there
was one actor whose performance seemed
to get a little too real if you ask
Blake Harrison in 2016 Harrison sat down
with nme and played a game of who would
you which saw him pulling questions out
of a bow and answering frankly one of
those questions was who would you
replace in the in between us he didn't
hesitate with his answer that's easy
James who plays Jay because he likes to
constantly fart just before someone says
action you've got to act through his
farts Harrison goes on to explain that
fans of the show will actually be able
to tell when Buckley's co-stars are
dealing with one of his stinkers drawing
a scene by their subtle reactions so go
back and watch something in between us
and watch if you can see this kind of
face during the
acting Harrison explained that if you do
see that kind of face it's quote the
face of smelling James as fat whilst
you're trying to just
act there's something inherently
childish about farts let's face it even
when adults rip one knowing it's a
normally bodily function will often
bring about an irresistible urge to
giggle like a child so it should come as
no surprise that when filming stranger
things with a cast made up almost
entirely of kids farts were pretty
regular on set according to the show's
creators it was mostly the boys who
wouldn't stop farting so much so that it
caused real problems during film in as
revealed in an article in Entertainment
Weekly written by The Duffer Brothers
the behavior of the boys began to dip a
little as they got toward the latter
stages of the first season much of the
frustration of Milly Bobby Brown the
only girl in the main cast at the time
the duffers recall was shooting a scene
in the abandoned bus and one of the boys
decides to fight more than once it
became so toxic in the bus that the crew
had to temporarily evacuate I don't feel
good about this I don't feel good about
this following numerous delays the duer
Brothers released a cast wide Mo that
urged everyone to get on the ball so
they could finish what they started
after our little talk the boys rallied
together and did some of their best most
emotional work on the show we're proud
of them for so many reasons and this is
one of them it's such a great group of
future stars farting aside hey at least
the farts weren't coming from the
demoran we can't even imagine how bad
that would smell there's no denying that
the beautiful Swedish star Alysia Vanda
is one of the most talented performers
in Hollywood she has been nominated for
both Golden Globes and batist and even
took home the Oscar for best supporting
actress for a part in the Danish girl
with such prestigious honors on her
resume it's fair to assume that Vanda
goes all in on every role she takes and
that includes the occasional fight in a
2016 interview with British Vogue Vanda
shed some light on some of the possible
repercussions of her impressive work
ethic when asked about her most
embarrassing moment she admitted that
she once broke wind while shooting a
scene I was going to give birth in this
scene we went for take and I just went
for it and I F should and take because I
I pushed so hard although she doesn't
disclose what film this was shot for one
can imagine that it must have been quite
a traumatic
[Music]
experience